today i'm going to be speaking with
amanda mackey who's an attorney and also
a republican strategist and i'm hoping
to get
some insight amanda into how you see
the sort of last four years of the
republican party and maybe we can just
work
backwards why do you think trump lost in
2020
um i have said all along and thank you
for having me on your show
um but i have said all along i think
this election in 2020 was a referendum
on the pandemic
it was really a coronavirus election and
how
some people viewed the handling of
president trump as
not wearing a mask not enforcing that
not pushing and promoting those policies
versus joe biden who was you know in his
basement
he was kind of in hiding and seclusion
which maybe a lot of people
actually agreed with uh that it was you
had to be isolated you should be
and so i think it was really the
dichotomy of how people
viewed the pandemic and how they viewed
the
the response to the coronavirus by the
two different camps
i i basically agree with you i mean i've
said before that if you look at
countries where world leaders handled
the virus
well or at least the perception is that
they did and you talk about new zealand
you talk about australia other places
had trump just said hey you know what
we're printing
mega masks if he had said that on march
20th of 2020
and we're letting the doctors handle
this i think he essentially sails to
re-election and i think the the proof is
and maybe here we'll start to disagree
his major campaign promises he didn't do
any of them the u.s mexico border wall
he added 50 miles he was going to
replace obamacare
he didn't do it he said he would pay off
the debt within four years
he increased it right so so i and it
really didn't matter it re i don't and
we can talk about
why it didn't matter but i think without
it without question
if he just handles the pandemic
moderately well he wins
i think that he viewed his handling of
the pandemic
ultimately as a success because
you do now have uh three or four
depending on the country
uh um vaccines that are on the market
at least in the united states at the end
of his term there were two vaccines on
the market
which i have always said having you know
worked in healthcare policy as a
healthcare attorney i mean that's
nothing short of nobel peace prize
winning and you can't say that it's not
now you can't just say that was all
president trump but
certainly pushing on all the levers to
get that to market he said that during
the campaign season and people laughed
at him people mocked him and said
there's no way he's just
lying and in december we were
vaccinating people
well but let's break that down a little
bit though because there's a bunch of
pieces there
so okay um yes trump
certainly funded uh the manufacturer of
vaccines and he pre-pre did the
pre-purchasing of vaccines on spec
before we even knew whether these
vaccines were going to be approved
that's that's good
any any president would do that i mean
to give him too much credit for that
seems a little strange but when you
think about
the the trajectory there were people
saying
december it's never going to happen in
may
goldman sachs put out to the month
an accurate prediction saying based on
the research that's being done around
the world
we expect health care workers to start
being vaccinated in in november
and here's where i really am curious
like what exactly you think trump did on
vaccination because
the pfizer vaccine was developed by
turkish immigrants to germany
the moderna vaccine was sequenced before
donald trump
even knew what was going on with the
pandemic
uh so i'm like what exactly did trump do
on the vaccines maybe we can figure it
out
well i think just pushing on every lever
of the government to get that domain
operation warp speed even um
you know even uh dr fauci's boss
dr francis collins of the nih has said
that
operation work speed deserves a lot of
credit
and so i think when you have a ceo which
obviously he was for many years um as
president you know there is just uh
i think he had just the line of sight to
make sure that this happens
and you can say that you know well this
was all in the works well mrnas have
been studied for
a decade so yes i mean technically
pharmaceuticals are
always in the works um but you know
pushing that through to happen in
december
no one believed that but what did he do
to push him
for that who did he push though what did
he push
well i can't say exactly what he pushed
it didn't work in the trump
administration but what i can say
is that when he said every day we're
working through operation warp speed
um to get this done uh you know
everything that comes together
through the government whether it's
lifting uh
regulations or making it easier to get
through
the chambers of government i worked in
congress for
you know a decade and it's not easy to
just get through a very
clunky federal government and
bureaucratic system but amanda what what
regulations
resulted in vaccines you're gonna have
to
you're gonna have to give me something
specific because so far you said you
don't actually know but trump said he
was working hard which often means
watching fox news
and tweeting what what what regulations
were lifted to make this happen more
quickly
look i i again i'm not going to give
specifics because i don't know exactly
what he did and he never said what he
did right so you don't know he did
anything
i'm sorry you can't really say he did
anything then
i think that's absolutely false now you
can look back and say well he said this
or he said that and that wasn't true
but what the ultimate result was these
vaccines coming to market i don't think
you can deny that
deny which part that the vaccines were
were made
that the the vaccines were made in
record time
in record time they were made and i i am
sure
that there are regulations that were
lifted there were things within the
government that were done
by this administration to ensure that
that happened
uh with record speed i mean usually it
takes a decade
not for mrna vaccines and therapeutics
to come to market not for mrna vaccines
all right
let's move on amanda because i do have
other things i want to talk about but
if at some point there's something
specific you can tell me you know trump
did rather than just he was claiming
that he was doing stuff
we will we will report it about claiming
i mean even when the nih head
like i said who is dr fauci's boss said
operation warp speed deserves credit
he didn't say pfizer deserves credit he
said operation warp speed operation work
speed was a function
of the trump administration yes the now
the two vaccines
that were first approved weren't part of
it they did pre-purchase
vaccines but uh fine okay good so
let's talk a little bit about policy my
interpretation
of the republican party right now and
and basically since the pandemic is that
it's
essentially a party of no it's we don't
want to do infrastructure
we don't want to do coronavirus
guidelines uh we don't want to do
uh daca we don't want to do tax reform
we don't want to so so there's been
really no
substantive proposals of policy of what
they want certainly we don't want to do
any changes to gun
legislation now i've said i don't know
that it's a bad strategy for republicans
and what i mean by that is
when you look at a candidacy like
madison cawthorne for example
his aide or his staffer straight up said
we're not running a policy office
we're running a communications office
it's memes and tweets and talking about
i can put two guns
on my wheelchair and all this sort of
stuff so my question is
do you think that this is a viable
long-term strategy
it might actually be like i don't know
that the republican party really needs
policy given who's voting for them right
now
well the republican party doesn't
control a single lever of the government
in washington right now
but the last two years of the trump
administration they did
uh they had the senate and the white
house
they had the white house and they had
the senate um and the house was
controlled by democrats
right so if you're looking if you're
talking about right now because you were
talking about topics
for right now because certainly trump
tried to do infrastructure and the
democrats said
no um but if you're looking at issues
right now
i think i mean look mitt romney did an
interview
and you know mitt romney is the the king
of rhinos i guess you could say i mean
he would probably be the most
moderate the most willing to work with
democrats and even he has said that
going at this alone on the corona virus
bill
relief bill was wrong he and
i believe those nine other republican
senators visited with the president the
beginning of february and said mr
president let's pare this bill down
mr president we have other ideas and
president biden did not not only did he
not listen i mean he didn't
pay attention to a single one of their
interests then it sounds like staff was
involved in this
yeah so the point is if you want to look
back on president trump he passed
five coronavirus bills with bipartisan
support
and president biden didn't do that with
bipartisan support but amanda that's
that's an indictment of republicans
that's in it that's an indict the fact
you're absolutely right
when it was trump saying we have to get
money to businesses and the american
people democrats didn't say
we are going to deny this to trump
merely because he's in the other party
because the american people need it
when democrats said okay well now it's
us we'll do a relief bill that's very
similar to what trump did
republicans said we're not participating
at all so
what you've just said is arguably the
biggest indictment of the obstructionist
republicans that i can imagine
misinterpreting what i said
no i don't think so using your own facts
because what i said is that the
republicans went to visit with president
biden
yeah and he dismissed everything that
they said he didn't take a single thing
into account he didn't even work with
them
he didn't even come to the table and say
let's sit down and talk
what concessions did trump make to
democrats he largely blamed it on staff
as did republicans the staff saying
we're not interested but what
concessions did trump make to democrats
on the coveted bills
uh kennedy center funding uh certainly
other pieces of the of the bill that
ultimately the law that republicans were
raped over the coals for
kennedy center wasn't that like 3
million bucks or something
it doesn't matter it's the fact that you
know this is what's interesting to me
yeah president uh trump was impeached by
the house
and then three months later he has nancy
pelosi sit down with steven mnuchin
because they obviously
trump and her didn't have a relationship
right and he said sit down
and work something out for the american
people and they did that's leadership
you know you don't pout and say i don't
like her so i'm not going to work with
her
fine did biden said i don't have to work
with you guys because we have 50 50 and
kama will be the
tie-breaking vote so i don't have to
work with you guys so i'm not going to
right trump but but i think isn't the
difference amanda that
trump didn't trump would have done that
if he had had the luxury of having the
house he just didn't
that's not that's not anything to pro i
mean it was just a reality
we can't work in hypotheticals but i
look at someone who was impeached in the
house by nancy pelosi
and three months later she sat down with
his treasury secretary and hammered out
a bill for the american people but the
reason she had to sit down with her
the reason she had to sit down with
mnuchin was trump
you know didn't want to play in the
sandbox with her anymore because of the
impeachment it's sort of like a
criticism of trump had his proxy work
with her the ultimate result was a
coveted relief bill wasn't it
yeah just like with biden right the
ultimate result was a coveted relief
a partisan coveted relief bill a
partisan covered relief bill
is it partisan if if 75 of americans
support it that's tens of millions of
republicans what's partisan stupid
relief
of which uh 90 of this bill does not go
to covet relief
we've debunked so we because we i've
debunked that extensively
i don't wanna jump into that um uh so so
let's not
jump into that in the few minutes we
have left
what is the policy right now that you
think
republicans should be focusing on what
policy now i know you're saying
well they don't control anything right
now okay fine but when trump controlled
everything
you still had democrats proposing things
and saying this is what we would like to
see
what are the main policy points you
think would be advantageous to the
republican party right now to be working
on
well the republican party can't work on
anything right now
it would have been nice if the democrats
proposed an actual infrastructure bill
because
as you know infrastructure is a key word
for bipartisanship
right but when you have a bill that's
introduced that even democrats can't
agree on
uh where the majority of it is not for
actual roads and bridges but this isn't
my question
i'm sorry i i didn't ask anything i'm
just saying what should be the policy
priorities of republicans
well if if republicans were in control
um i think that uh lowering healthcare
costs
should be an important uh demonstration
of their uh
of their efforts to help americans uh
especially after the last year americans
have consumed a lot of health care so
making sure that
you know whether it's deductibles
out-of-pocket costs are
are not uh prohibitively expensive for
americans and certainly making sure drug
costs come down
i think you can work in a bipartisan way
on that um
look i know immigration is the third
rail of politics
but we we have got to re-visit
our immigration policies um when you ha
you know our immigration policies are
tailored towards the 1990s mentality
of while you have people coming from
central america and mexico
to the united states to work adults you
don't have
seven-year-olds walking over by
themselves you don't have these coyotes
you know dropping these kids over the
fence that's the new
normal in our immigration and if
republicans and democrats don't tackle
this
uh that's going to have a huge impact on
the united states and workers in the
united states we still have high
unemployment numbers
and if we're allowing mass migration to
happen and not doing anything to enforce
the borders we're going to have problems
in all 50 states
so so health care and immigration would
be your priorities if republicans could
get things done right now
i think they just need to sit down and
reevaluate the situation i mean what's
happening right now is that you have
coyotes bringing children across the
border
why because people they don't our
policies are not to send children back
title 42 don't send the children back
they're allowed to stay here
that's why parents are willing to
separate from a seven-year-old
and allow a stranger to take them across
the border for a better life in america
we have got to prioritize what are the
needs of the united states i'm sure
there are needs that the united states
has
and to say okay we are going to allow
for
uh you know this worker that worker that
we need
and then set immigration policies that
way but if we're nothing we're a country
of laws
and you have to re-evaluate the entire
situation you can't look at laws from 30
years ago or 40 years ago and say
well this is our immigration policy
clearly it's not working
yeah i mean it it strikes me when you
look at for for americans
the immigrant i'm not saying immigration
is not an issue it just ranks very low
in in priorities the priorities are uh
you know the state of the economy jobs
wages healthcare you did mention and i
think that that certainly would be there
although we might disagree about the
solutions
immigration is just quite far down the
list for most americans well i think
that may change when you have in the
month of march alone 171
000 migrants coming to our southern
border yeah
it's not really changing i mean the
polling is pretty steady it's just not
that important to most people i'm not
saying it doesn't matter i just think
it's a very inside politics
issue for most people uh i i don't know
that it's a winning issue for
either party to be quite frank well it
may not be a winning issue
but we have an immigration crisis
unfortunately the president vice
president have not visited the southern
border as bad as it is
they still haven't gone there and i
understand they don't want the media to
be there to see what it is
what would they learn from going though
what would they learn from going that
someone can't tell them what would they
learn
from going to the border that someone
can't tell them
it's it's it's the perception you're the
president of the united states you have
a southern border crisis
and you refuse to go got it kamala
harris has been tasked with this what
has she
done in the last two weeks since she has
been tasked with this to show that this
is an
important issue there's a crisis on our
border seven-year-olds are being dropped
over
uh you know fences to be able to come
into the united states
no that's fine that's fine but so but
you you're saying it's it's opted the
going to the border is about optics they
could learn everything
from that transparency there's been a
media blackout
and that's not transparency this was
supposed to be the most transparent
administration
and it hasn't been yeah oh so i do think
that they need to be more transparent
with the video
from some of the facilities they've
released some but but not others so
that's a beautiful point of agreement
amanda on which uh
on which we can end amanda mackey
attorney and republican strategist
telling us uh many different things uh
which i
am sure our audience will find very
interesting amanda i really appreciate
your time
thank you